we often highlight women on our show who
aren't afraid to color outside the lines
we actually call them wild flowers and
because today is international women's
day we are teaming up with wounded
warrior project to introduce you to a
rose who is anything but delicate
meet donna
my name is donna pratt
and i am from o'fallon illinois i am a
retired army sergeant and i am a woman
veteran warrior when i joined the
military right after high school i
decided that the army wasn't for me then
i got out in
1998 but after 9 11 i decided to rejoin
because i felt like there was something
more that i needed to be doing we were
deployed to iraq i got a chance to be an
armorer we had a vehicle that was
jarring up and down and a few weeks
later i had swollen ankles and didn't
pay attention because i had a job that i
needed to do walked into the clinic and
had fractures torn laments nerve damage
and doctors telling me most likely i
wouldn't be able to walk again
um which was devastating news
i was in a wheelchair for about two
years
i went through
several
bouts of surgeries physical therapy and
prayer i was asked to come to a wounded
warrior project soldier ride which is a
bicycle ride i thought they were crazy i
went on that bike ride it helped me gain
a sense of myself that i didn't even
know i had that being in a wheelchair
wasn't my death sentence
sports and wounded warrior project
brought me out of depression and brought
me out of a sense of not even wanting to
be alive
now i'm happy i got a chance to be
married and now i'm carrying other
warriors by telling my story to know
that no matter what life isn't
impossible i developed a model for
myself i don't adapt to life i make life
adapt to me
[Applause]
i love that motto so much thank you
[Music]
you